Given a graph and a source vertex S,
what's the distance of all other
vertices of the graph from S?
To find out, you can perform a
breadth-first search or a BFS for short.
Here's how you might do it.
For each vertex,
we'll keep a shortest distance.
Now, the source is a distance
of 0 edges away from itself,
so let's set its distance to 0.
Now for all the rest, you don't
know any of the distances yet, so
let's set them all to infinity.
Next, start the source and
look at its immediate neighbors.
These neighbors are one
away from the source, so
let's update their distances to be one.
Now, let's visit
the neighbor's neighbors.
Now, most of these are not yet
visited, so
they must be one more away from
the previous nodes we visited.
But one of these, we've seen already,
so that means we already know its
shortest distance, and so
we can leave that one alone.
And you'll continue this process
until you've seen all the vertices.
The way a BFS works is a little bit like
dropping a drop of water into a bucket.
The drop hits the source, and
that causes a ripple of waves through
the graph where we
propagate the differences.
These waves are sometimes
called frontiers.
Here's a pseudocode for
a sequential algorithm that
implements the scheme we just saw.